hola qué tal según las últimas
proyecciones ya con el 100% de los votos
escrutados
marcelo reveló de se usa obtendría la
reelección con 60 puntos 8 por ciento en
segundo lugar quedó la candidata de
izquierda ana gómez con 12.8 por ciento
y en tercer lugar
andrew aventura de ultraderecha con 11.9
por ciento todos los candidatos
lamentaron el alto índice de abstención
que ya pronosticaban algunos sondeos
quedó en 60 más del 60 por ciento de
abstención fue una jornada pacífica se
registró con total normalidad sin
embargo por causa de la pandemia muchos
portugueses fuera del territorio
nacional no pudieron ejercer su derecho
al voto además se encuentra un país en
confinamiento con muchas restricciones y
en la última semana más de 74 mil
personas infectadas por kobe más de 1300
fallecidos y por supuesto esto iba a
afectar estas elecciones presidenciales
marcelo reveló de souza asumirá este
segundo mandato el próximo
9 de marzo un mandato por cinco años más
y se para que minutos ofrezca un
discurso luego de que ya se han
pronunciado el resto de los candidatos